it was one of the most daring heists in
British criminal history Pentagon would
have been a target for thieves for years
and years and years it's a dream of a
lot of career criminals out if I had the
opportunity to get into a vault jewelry
gold and cash at least 14 million pounds
worth and most of it still missing I'm
told by underworld sources that it's two
three four times that amount I don't
think we'll ever know this is one of the
highest value burglaries ever to have
taken place in Britain a gang of aging
criminals who had already spent years in
jail the hearts back to a kind of Golden
Age of robbery if you like in the 50s
60s into the 70s and 80s a plot that
read like a movie script this was the
one this was the big one
they committed the perfect crime but
what happened afterwards was a disaster
this was their pension plan their one
last job
sparkling diamonds fair value running
into millions are giving Hatton Garden
sleepless nights with London now a world
center for diamonds jewel bandits have
made this city fair affair their
favorite target
there have been widespread thefts of
precious stones worth hundreds of
thousands the Hatton Garden safe deposit
vault was built in the 1940s the first
of its kind celebrated in a news
bulletin of the day nearly a thousand
individual safes are contained within
this mess of steel and reinforced
concrete this particular site in Hatton
Garden have been a potential target for
about twenty years at least for certain
members of the gang the four men who put
together the plot at criminal pedigrees
stretching back over decades of
notorious crimes
Brian reader the oldest put 76 referred
to by the others as the governor he was
once jailed for a notorious robbery and
in the same case acquitted of murdering
an undercover police officer he was
found not guilty he went on the Hatton
Garden raid on a free travel pass it
wasn't even his own Terry Perkins spent
his 67th birthday breaking into the
vault
he was once jailed for 22 years for a
robbery he's a diabetic and took with
him into the vault
three days of Medicine
john collins aged 74 his criminal record
of robbery and theft stretched all the
way back to 1961 on the raid he used his
own car it was easily traced and it led
to the gangs capture Danny Jones the
youngest of the ringleaders at 60 since
the 1970s he'd been jailed for burglary
and theft when he bought a power tool
for the raid he gave his own name and
address in court he was described as an
eccentric who slept in his mother's
dressing gown and a fez hat Karl wood
was involved in the first night of the
raid he denied he was there I was
astounded when the identification of
these robbers was revealed by the police
because they really were old-school
villains they all had a background
virtually all of them had a background
in robbery an old-fashioned type of
criminals who the classic type of London
bred post-war villains when they saw
some of those names come up I assume
that they've retired I assume that
they'd that they've most that they've
moved on they began planning it three
years before the raid according to
evidence found on Danny Jones's laptop
computer it showed that he had been
researching power drills detectives
believe that one of them later visited
the vault to discuss renting a
safe-deposit box
and observe the layout a security guard
told police he had shown several
potential customers around the premises
but he hadn't kept a record of their
details the vault owners also employed a
number of temporary security guards in
the months before the raid this part of
London is the very heartland of one of
Britain's most notorious crime
organisations in criminal parlance this
is their Manor but were they involved in
the raid the police don't think so but
at least two of the Raiders were
connected to the crime Network
and it's name crops up in conversations
bugged by the police it was said on the
street that the crime organization was
angry at such a raid on its territory it
was claiming it had property stolen from
the boxes and was demanding that those
involved gave it back by the Easter
weekend the gang were ready with
dramatic events of the night of Thursday
the second of April start with Brian
reader using a pensioners pass to travel
for free to Hatton Garden from his
hometown of Dartford in Kent at 8:20
others arrived in a white van driven by
John Collins they park in nearby leather
Lane this is Danny Jones and Karl wood
they're wearing high visibility
waistcoats to make themselves look like
gas contractors they walk along to look
at the target building 88 to 90 Hatton
Garden at 20 past 9 another man with red
hair appears he's carrying a black bin
bag on his shoulder
to avoid CCTV he goes into the building
by the front door other gang members
later referred to him as basil police
have never been able to identify him he
goes through to the back of the building
and from the inside opens the fire
escape door on Greville Street moments
later the white van pulls up by the door
the gang can be seen unloading wheelie
bins bags of tools and large metal
joists they appear to be struggling with
the wait there is no doubt this was
heavy hard work it was bold and daring
for them to try at their age and no
doubt they would have benefited from
probably having some younger fitter men
involved Colin's parked the van around
the corner and positions himself as
lookout in a building opposite the vault
police have never found the van
the gang carried their gear down the
fire escape to the basement courtyard
from the inside basal unbolted the back
door
two men climbed the stairs to the second
floor where they brought up and disabled
the lift from the ground floor one or
more of the gang dropped down the lift
shaft to the basement and forced open a
metal shutter they crawled out open to
the unlocked cupboard under the stairs
and disabled the alarm they cut the
power to the outer iron gate and slid it
open they smashed the lock off the
wooden main door and let in the others
they cut through the second iron gate
and drilled through the vault wall
concrete half a meter thick three holes
were made each one takes an agonizing
thirty minutes to drill the entrance is
just wide enough for Danny Jones a super
fit marathon runner and basil the
mystery raider to fit through it's
really a young man's game moving that
stuff around can be quite exhausting
they must have practiced somewhere else
because it's not just the drill hole
it's the setup of equipment there's a
lot of things to go in to get to place
before you actually start drill unknown
to them the damaged alarm managed to
send an SMS text alert and a security
guard is on his way to the premises but
this is where the gang again get lucky
because of a breakdown of communication
with a security company the police
failed to turn up the security guard
checks the front door sees nothing wrong
hears nothing unusual and goes away
trying to give them credit that you've
actually managed to go through the walls
but then look from there they get stuck
the robbers drilled through the wall but
the hole was blocked by a steel cabinet
holding the boxes the
Ram needed to push over the cabinet had
broken they leave and come back the next
day with a new tool Brian reader however
doesn't return on Easter Saturday John
Collins and Danny Jones get into
Collins's white Mercedes and go shopping
they needed a new hydraulic ram and this
was first big mistake was going out on
the Saturday and openly buying the piece
new piece of equipment in Twickenham at
a tool shop they drive around Hatton
Garden in the white Mercedes looking to
see if anyone has raised the alarm
confident their plot hasn't been
discovered they return it to carry on
where they left off but Karl Wood said
the prosecution loses his nerve and
leaves the scene it looked like whoever
had got in through the hull had almost
panicked in what they were doing boxes
were strewn everywhere it was a
completely across the board from watches
to loose stones to finished items to
rings pendants bracelets necklaces the
whole cross-section of different types
of jury just 73 of the 999 deposit boxes
were opened an estimated 14 million
pounds worth of goods gone it was big
news this fire the Metropolitan Police
Scotland Yard in other words they say
they're investigating a robbery the
scene still remains chaotic down there
vault is covered in dust and debris and
the floor is strewn with discarded
safety deposit boxes numerous power
tools compliance rings an asset sat in
there half the people they've got their
own personal effects along with clients
effects so that's like a double whammy
one post-it note summed up the feelings
of the street in a direct way
the gang had been careful in the vault
and left no forensic clue such as
fingerprints blood or saliva no camera
had caught any clear image of their
faces and there were no witnesses but
there was a growing amount of
circumstantial evidence a key moment in
investigation was when one of the young
detectives on the team was able to
identify Collins's vehicle once you have
identified an individual you can then
start to work out from them much in the
same way as the homicide detective uses
the dead body to work out work backwards
from to see who brought the crime to
bear there and that moment was actually
one I think of euphoria for the team
because now it opens up other
opportunities you can then start to look
at the call data you can see who they've
been contacting you have a start point
for surveillance so you can actually
start to follow them around to see who
they're meeting look at their lifestyle
the white Mercedes was caught on a CCTV
camera in Hatton Garden on the first
night of the raid and a NPR automatic
number plate retrieval showed it was
used to get a key bit of equipment on
the second day of the raid police found
it parked outside John Collins's North
London home surveillance teams followed
him and the car they saw Collins and
Danny Jones together inside the vehicle
Jones they discovered had visited the
same DIY store at the same time as the
car had been driven there Collins and
Jones's phone records revealed
conversations with Terry Perkins before
the raid surveillance on those three men
showed them later having meetings with
Bryan reader in a North London pub
police had connected the four ringleader
it's almost too good to be true that
they would not think about throwing
their phones away every time they use
them or destroying their laptops when
they looked up drills on them things
like that these were elementary mistakes
they made members of the gang boasted of
how they got into the vault police
surveillance even caught Terry Perkins
showing Brian reader how they did it and
what he missed after he dropped out this
gang also do not watch CSI or lock stock
and barrel where people use a phone for
one minute and it's it's gone
don't just mace actually with their
attitude they deserve to be caught the
ringleaders recruited other men to help
them William Lincoln known as Billy the
fish stored the loot at his home
immediately after the raid plumber Hugh
Doyle the gangs drinking mate let them
use his workshop for the loot handover
you're looking at the possibility of
appealing the conviction and how likely
do you think it is you'll get you'll get
a change to it abscent are really pretty
strongly cups how did you feel when the
verdict came back in very I was good it
was inevitable at some point they would
divide up the goods it's what they will
call the slaughter and that was the
moment we were waiting for and I had
said to the team from the outset that's
the prize and it's bringing them
together with the goods that meant that
actually we would secure the successful
convictions that we have done however
that takes many weeks
six weeks after the burglary in a series
of raids detectives arrested the
suspects police found millions of pounds
worth of goods hidden around the homes
of the ringleaders I'm surprised that
arrangements had been made to shift
their Goods very very quickly and that's
clear that was clearly a problem that
they were left with they were left with
these goods in their homes at one house
they found a copy of forensics for
dummies you don't keep clothing you
don't keep gear from the robbery you
don't keep items used and the way you
use your clothes as well you have to
limit the evidence that the police can
obtain in my view they were very much
analog criminals operating in a digital
world
Brian reader got eight years in prison
for his involvement in the 1983 Brinks
Mac robbery where a gang stole 26
million pounds in gold bullion at
Heathrow Airport reader was a friend and
neighbor of Kenneth Noi they were jailed
together for handling the Brinks Matt
gold in the same case they were both
acquitted of murdering an undercover
policeman John Fordham the detective was
stabbed to death by Noi who had found
the officer hiding in his garden no I
was acquitted after claiming
self-defense the jury cleared reader
when he insisted he simply wasn't there
Perkins is a legendary name liked by a
lot of other criminals terry Perkins
also made a name for himself in 1983 in
the security express robbery
6 million pounds was stolen from the
vaults of Sakura core Perkins got 22
years for the security express job and
yet he came out of prison some years
later ready to commit more crimes John
Collins and Danny Jones both had a
string of convictions stretching back
several decades these were the
masterminds behind the Hat
garden raid experienced criminals with
solid backgrounds in theft but in
letters written to me from prison Danny
Jones said he wanted to show police
where he had buried his share of the 14
million pounds loot I want to get back
my charity out and garden burglary Burma
won't release me to the police will a
load of bull I'm the only person that
will to know where it is deep down I
want to do the right thing and give it
back I want to make amends to all my
loved ones and show um try to change
eventually they did let Jones out to
show police where he had hidden his
stash it was here at this North London
Cemetery they pulled out two bags from
under a graveside plaque the detectives
asked is this everything yes he said
that was all his share what Jones didn't
realize was that the police had already
found another bigger bag of his hidden
gems and cash in a nearby plot police
found out when they bugged the gangs
cars and heard Jones talking about
hiding the loot in the cemetery they
would still want some profit from the
criminality and even if they're going to
serve a sentence they will do their
utmost to try and reduce the sentence to
as little as possible Jones also
questioned why an aging bunch of
burglars would be held in such high
security well let me tell you there's
Armia like super sportsmen compared with
this gang run they can barely walk one
is K it's at least seventy six in other
words Ark condition 68 another 75 can't
remember his name
60 year old with two new hips and nice
Crohn's disease I won't go on it's a
joke it's really wrong because I can't
see somebody's so-called gang getting
prudish once sentenced
Jones says he wrote to the Archbishop of
Canterbury for help in improving prison
conditions the reply was he couldn't
help me but will pray for me in his next
church service he also said so Lee
you've got yourself mixed up and he
hadn't garden heist and finished up by
saying just being famous must now seem
like a pretty poor reward best wishes
Lambeth Palace
after the raid of the Hatton Garden safe
deposit company went bust it had been
used mostly by local craftsmen a small
business which had served the jewelry
industry for nearly 70 years the vast
majority of people working here are just
ordinary people with ordinary lives
running workshops making goods right now
I have had about 25 percent back and I
know they're on the next lot that were
found at the church art I know there's
some of those pieces they're mine as
well so right now it looks like I would
get about a third back people came up to
me because of my position in the boss
Kim can you help us what can we do and
you could see they were quite cut up
about the whole thing there you know
this thing you know my life's work has
gone as I think the emotional side would
was as powerful if not more so than the
monetary loss in in many cases police
have found only one-third of the
estimated 14 million pounds of loot so
where are the missing millions and where
is basil the man who got away there's a
twenty thousand pound reward for
information on him and for stolen goods
the loot the police recovered was well
mostly the cheap stuff what's still
missing are many loose precious stones
and gold bars and coins that leaves at
the trial prosecutor somewhere out there
in the world a great deal of stolen
property that's been hidden disguised or
sold
some of it could easily been spent some
of it could have been paying off debts
covering expenses it could have been
invested elsewhere some of it will just
be hidden behind skirting boards down
drains in attics
well it takes the imagination because
it's a one-off it certainly takes the
imagination love money and so on that we
can take the feelings were the villains
you know I mean their career villains
they've taken something that doesn't
belong to them this is how that ice will
be remembered it will be remembered for
those few guys who were in their you
know their late sixties to their late
seventies and I won't be surprised if
there's a film option actually been
taken out now installing theirs is a
remarkable story and it's far from over
one of the ringleaders put it like this
when you think about it we must have
been crackers we got to be stone
crackers
you